Now let's go through a few quick
fixes to spiff up your own profile.
You can follow along as I fix mine.
This guy here, if you don't know,
is Andre the Giant.
Professional wrestler, actor,
and all around good dude.
However I'm going to
need a better picture,
preferably of myself,
if I want to connect with recruiters.
Also, I'm missing a bunch of other
information like my name and
where I'm located.
Git Hub has given me a prompt
to flush out my profile
to help other GitHub
users get to know me.
Let's follow their advice.
I can edit my profile by
clicking through here.
Here's where I can upload a new picture.
Then I fill out my information.
My name, the URL of my blog,
company, and finally my location.
Now that I'm done with that, I can also
change the names of my repositories,
if any need a better name.
My repository names look fine.
If I did want to change the name,
I click the repository
then go to Settings.
Here's where you can change the name.
Also, don't forget to comment your code.
You'll, probably,
end up showing off a couple sections
of your code to an interviewer.
Make sure it's commented and working